hey guys so update on jenna
she is um
she's not doing so well jenna jameson's
partner leor bitten shares an update on
her health following her recent gbs
diagnosis neurologist
she came in today
and
she wants to run some more tests
to make sure it's
gilliam bar syndrome on monday the 47
year old former adult film star
announced on instagram that she had been
diagnosed with the rare autoimmune
disorder that affects the body's nerves
and muscles after feeling sick for weeks
i'm in the hospital still you've gotten
some answers
um i'm dealing with
jillian
beret
syndrome so i'm
working through that but on wednesday
her partner posted an update to
instagram revealing that her condition
failed to improve and doctors were
questioning her diagnosis
it was kind of confirmed but after the
treatment
now they have second out so they
doubting it that second thoughts they
doubting it
so
not sure so tomorrow
she's gonna be running a lot of tests
a lot of neurological tests so to see
what's going on and what we're gonna do
with her so we'll see lior elaborates on
how jenna's doing her legs become very
thin
they're thinning down so they become
super skinny he also thanks her fans for
their continued love and support thank
you to everyone but
thank you for everyone for the
well wishes we really appreciate that
thank you god bless you this update
comes after jenna posted a video to
social media from her hospital bed
revealing in the caption that she
started an ivig treatment and would most
likely stay in the hospital until her
treatment was complete i'm in a hospital
in hawaii right now
i see all your dms and i
appreciate it so much prior to sharing
her diagnosis lior talked about what led
to her hospitalization she's not feeling
so good
she was actually throwing up for a
couple weeks and
we had to take her to the hospital he
went on to explain that the hospital
gave her a ct scan and cleared her to
return home but things quickly got worse
she came back home she couldn't carry
herself her muscles in her
legs were very weak so
she wasn't able to walk to the bathroom
she was falling on the way
back or to the bathroom and then i would
have to pick her up and put her in bed
and then eat within two days it got
really
uh
not so good her legs started to
not older
she couldn't she wasn't able to walk and
he said that even with a walker jenna
wasn't able to hold up her own body
weight she
collapsed her
her knees kind of buckled
so she wasn't able to hold her
body weight
so
i decided
she needs to go to the hospital
according to the cdc gbs affects around
1 in 100 000 people and is a rare
autoimmune disorder in which a person's
own immune system damages the nerves
causing muscle weakness and sometimes
paralysis
the disorder can cause symptoms that
persist for a few weeks to several years
and the cdc says that most people
recover fully but some have permanent
nerve damage and in rare cases people
have died as for jenna she says she's
just focused on getting healthy so i
just uh had
an infusion
and
we're just working towards getting
better